also speaking of religion i had to bring
up this clip this might be my favorite
clip
from the entire uh thanksgiving weekend
we've been told that joe biden is a
devout catholic we've been told that
donald trump is a terrible horrible
sinner and awful man whose doesn't know
anything about the bible you remember he
referred to
second corinthians as two corinthians
which by the way some people actually do
but anyway he was mocked for this he's
never read a bible in his life
you didn't see the same treatment when
joe biden over the weekend
referred to a book of the bible that i
i'm not familiar with
the book of palms and if we do
and i'm sure we can we can proclaim
the promised with the promised who wrote
these following words the lord is my
strength and my shield
the promised the promised wrote that
that's uh
i thought i had read at least a decent
number of books of the bible i guess i
had missed
the promise i think he might be
referring to the psalmist
no doubt joe biden will blame this on
his childhood stutter
just like he blames everything on his
childhood stutter which magically
disappeared from the age of what
7 to 75 and then that childhood stutter
came back again i think if it comes back
at 75 it's not a childhood stutter
anymore
i think it's an adult cognitive decline
but in this case i don't think it's that
joe biden is
in such decline that he forgets the book
of this bible that he's devoted to he's
not a devout catholic in any way
he supports abortion which is not
permissible and he supports abortion in
public life which is not permissible
that's why he was denied
the eucharist at mass a number of months
ago rightly denied that
joe biden ought to be excommunicated
excommunication
can be an act of mercy we it gets back i
guess to our death penalty conversation
justice can be an act of compassion
because the purpose of something like an
excommunication
or of this chiding is
to change the person's heart it's
rehabilitative
punishment can be a rehabilitative thing
we used to know that
you do this to say you are in a very
grave state you are in
imperiling your soul joe biden who
professes to be a devout catholic you
need to repent
and change your views but no one's
forcing him to do that which
is much crueler to joe biden if you
actually believe
that catholic religion that he pretends
to believe he sues nuns people who are
devout catholics don't sue nuns
and people who are devout catholics
though they may not have read every
single word of the bible
i'm willing to grant that because
catholics read the bible liturgically
you read it as part of mass but sure
maybe they don't
they haven't read every word of it
they've read the psalms
the psalms are one of the most
significant
well-known books of the bible and i just
don't think joe biden takes any of that
very seriously i think that his true
religion that he's devoted to
is secularism i think that's the true
religion
of virtually everybody on the left today
and it's a false religion and it's a
wicked religion for
our politics and it's going to lead to a
lot of misery and it's going to ruin a
lot of souls
in the life hereafter but it is a strong
religion and and we need to call it for
what it is
he is the potential president did you
miss out on our amazing black friday
deal
well we have a cure for your fomo
that's right today only join us as a
daily wire member
for 50 off with code dw50 over at
dailywire.com
subscribe since last year's deal we've
added so many more features and products
to our membership program
and we're extremely excited about it
we've added more exclusive readers past
content
our insider and above members can now
stream our content on apple tv and roku
which is huge because we're adding more
content every day such as
bringing you the michael knowles show
five days a week starting friday
december 4th
and if you're an all access member you
get to join all access live our
exclusive daily live streams
with me or one of the other hosts where
we can talk to you directly about just
about anything
and more importantly where we can steal
your ideas and use them on the shows
we offered this incredible deal last
year but we may not be able to offer it
again next year
so be sure to become a member today
using coupon code dw50
over at dailywire.com subscribe
you